Father in Heaven this morning again we
thank you for a gorgeous day outside and
father we just we thank you Father that
you have granted us a day of life today
father we pray that we would live up to
the the full potential of this day
uh here in the class as we learn in the
meetings tonight as people come father I
praise your name for the response last
night as Hearts were moved by your Holy
Spirit such an Evidence to us how can
anybody deny the presence of a god when
we see the mighty power of the moving of
the Holy Spirit like that and father
this morning we asked the Same Spirit
what Inspire us and would impress our
hearts and our minds would lead us into
all truth as you promised that he would
as we study this most important subject
of the gift of Prophecy in your Remnant
church and we ask and pray this in Jesus
name amen
yeah I thought that was awesome last
night I mean how can you
you know when when you hear brothers and
sisters when a person sits you know
people don't like to cry in public
and when you hear people sniffling
through a sermon you know the Holy
Spirit has just gone boom you know grab
the hearts of the people that is
powerful I'll tell you something for
those of you who want to get into
preaching
you can preach the lousiest sermon but
if you got a good Appeal on it it
recovers the whole thing personal forget
everything that you said that's the
whole point of the sermon it's not just
to get intellect if you can get the
heart and a person responds I mean
you've accomplished your mission
and so uh no I thought that was awesome
last night
and some of you had mentioned to me that
I wish he wouldn't have brought my name
into it but Scott was a church member of
mine in Ohio and that's where we met so
uh it was quite quite an experience
but I praise the Lord for it okay this
morning we were in the subject of
prophetic interpretation
and we were on page seven
finding page one the nature of
inspiration okay page seven at the very
top of the page and
I better go to page six here
because we're we're finishing up on page
seven we were looking at how we View
wgw which is supposed to be egw there on
that was uh
3C
that's at the bottom of page six so we
went on from there and we were just
looking at there's a couple quotes by
Ellen White that I think would be
beneficial to you at the top of page
seven notice the first one from selected
messages volume 1 page 21.
the Bible is written by inspired men
but it is not God's mode of thought and
expression
it is that of humanity God as a writer
is not represented
men will often say such an expression is
not like God
but God has not put himself in words in
logic in rhetoric on trial in the Bible
the writers of the Bible were God's
Penman not his pen
what we're reading in the Bible she says
this is not they're not the they're not
uh it's not God's mode of thought and
expression if God were to express it he
would have expressed it probably
differently
but he's expressing through humanity and
he's leaving it to those human channels
to express it in human words
the point is that God words things to
meet us in our fallen condition when we
get to heaven
the expressions in the Bible are very
Elementary although now they tax our
mind to the uttermost right how how much
of our brain do we use
10 at the most
some of us less
some of us less at certain times there
are times when I've used no percent of
my brain
some of the decisions I've made so it
God's communicated his word in a way
that you and I can grasp hold of him
and for that reason you and I should
never say well I can't understand the
Bible it's impossible to understand it
no God put it in human language for you
and I you follow what I'm saying any
questions on that
the writers of the Bible were God's
Penman not his pen look at the different
writers she says it is not the words of
the Bible that are inspired but the men
that were inspired
inspiration acts not on man's words or
his Expressions but on the man himself
who under the influence of the holy
spirit is imbued with thoughts
so the holy spirit gives man thoughts
but the words receive the impress of the
individual mind just like we had
yesterday we had four different people
watch this video and give four different
answers and they all gave correct
answers but each person Cindy's a point
person boom boom boom she gave points
um Ezekiel you how can I word your your
like the mark gospel Mark is the
shortest gospel and his was just right
to the point
um you know and you had the different
expressions from the same thing that's
the same that's what she's expressing
here the words receive the impress of
the individual mind
the Divine mind is diffused why do you
think God did that
use different people
why do you think God used different
people why do we got four different
Gospels
more complete story there's another
reason I think
lens credibility there's another reason
I think
I'm fishing okay
fishing
that's close to what I'm looking for
once to reach different kinds of people
have you ever noticed that you can reach
people that other people can't reach
Scott was it was it drove a big rig for
what do you say eight years or six years
I forget how many well four but last
night when he was talking in his story
but he'd driven before that but the
point is this
he can he has an opportunity now to
reach people in that same setting that
somebody else may not have opportunity
to reach
have you ever noticed that when you're
when you're reaching out to people
depending on your background depending
on your intellect some people for
example
some people love Mark Finley
some people hate him as far as his
preaching style goes Mark Finley can be
very mechanical if you watch Mark Finley
some people love Doug Batcher some
people hate him I'm not saying to hate
but you know what I'm saying I don't
like him at all I don't like listening
to that guy I like Mark Finley just like
in the Bible it was I like Apollos I
like Peter I like Paul why because they
had they would appeal to different
people's minds differently people could
relate to Paul some people could relate
to Paul the Tent Maker and The Scholar
some people could relate better to Luke
the doctor some people could relate
better to Apollos he was a very eloquent
speaker
you know
um do you understand that what I'm
getting at there
I think that's why God used different
people one of the reasons they were
other there were other good reasons
given there but I believe that's why God
uses different people and I believe
that's why God uses all of us so we
can't say well I guess there was
somebody else we got some real talented
people in here sometimes you sit in a
class like this and you're like man
there's so many talented people I've
heard some of these guys being man what
am I going to do don't ever think that
because you can reach people that nobody
else can reach
every one of you here
that includes those who aren't well I'm
not going to go into preaching I just
wanted it doesn't matter you know some
people will never be reached by
preaching some people we never come to
an Evangelistic meaning yellow white
says some people the only way they're
going to be reached is in their homes
you've got people who didn't come to the
meeting you're studying with people like
I wanted them to come I wanted them to
come they're not going to come you're
going to get the decision in the home
through personal Bible studies
you may do the Bible studies they come
to church it may be two years from now
that they make a decision it may be 10
years from now
they may never come to an Evangelistic
meeting
do you follow that so the Lord uses us
just go to work for the Lord leave it in
his hands but he uses us all because of
our different temperaments we can reach
different people and that's how he did
it in the scripture we have example of
that
the words receive the impress of the
individual mind it says the Divine mind
is diffused the Divine mind and will is
combined with the human mind and will
thus the utterances of man are the words
of God
it's really powerful I mean it's the
whole idea of divinity and Humanity
combined next statement
somebody had asked me this and I was
looking at it last night oh somebody had
asked me yesterday about these different
discrepancies and what do you say to
people you know when these things come
up how do you know that they're going to
pick this this and say well there's this
error in the Bible or this Aaron Ellen
White you know what are you going to say
to him listen to what she says
first selected message is 16 and 17.
some look at us Gravely and say don't
you think there might have been some
mistake in the copyists or in the
translators
this is all probable she says and the
mind that is so narrow that it will
hesitate and stumble over the
possibility or probability would be just
as ready to stumble over the mysteries
of the inspired word because their
feeble Minds cannot see through the
purposes of God
yet they would just as easily stumble
over plain facts that the common mind
will accept
and discern the Divine and to which
God's utterance is plain and beautiful
full of marrow and fatness all the
mistakes will not cause trouble to One
Soul
or cause any feet to stumble that would
not manufacture difficulties from the
plainest revealed truth
you know when I
I remember when I was at Mission College
we're going out studying with people I
remember guys coming back in and I've
done this now as a pastor you get a
Bible word to come in or something
Pastor I've got a hot interest man this
study this person is on fire
I remember Pastor Torres going to the
house and coming out you know afterwards
and telling the class that wasn't a hot
interest he was argumentative
you know there are some people that oh
but they always study with me never turn
me away sure they like to debate
you go in your hand they go in their
house and they'll debate no debate and
debate at least they're interacting and
so you think I've got a hot interest
and a lot of times the devil just uses
that to keep you off the trail the real
interest somewhere else
let me tell you this this morning
debating is fun for Adventists because
man I'll tell you we've got it down
we've had this but Ellen White have
writes a lot of counsel but I'll tell
you what you're never going to win one
soul from debate
never going to win one soul from debate
you'll probably turn them away faster
than you win them
you notice when Jesus ever got into a
position of debate and it was like I
mean what do you think these people came
and asked Jesus these questions
and and if he wanted to debate the very
topic they asked it on what do you think
that would have turned out like he would
have blown him out of the water boom you
know he knew what about this text this
text this text no what does he do how
many times has Jesus asked or somebody
asked Jesus a question and then he says
something it's like didn't he hear the
question he's talking something way over
here they asked something over here he
avoided the debate he went around to the
real Jesus perceived right through to
the real issue
and he just went right around it and
boom right to the heart Nicodemus comes
up to Jesus he's going to rub elbows
with a good teacher good teacher you and
I are kind of in the same you know we're
both teachers of Israel wants to you
know kind of warm up to him and Jesus
says let me tell you something Nicodemus
unless a man's born again he won't enter
the kingdom of God
where'd that come from
but you see that time and again the way
Jesus dealt with people
and um
so you know sometimes we get it's the
same thing as uh and I've gone through
this experience I told you earlier this
week boy that one text when I'm talking
to him about the Sabbath isn't there a
text isn't there a text that says
something oh so you find it right you go
oh look at this one look at this one so
you're going back to that study I've got
it now man this text is going to get
them this text is going to do it so you
get to your study
that one text isn't going to do it 50
million texts aren't going to do it when
the person is resistant to the truth
when a person is open to the truth I was
talking with uh Autumn and I were
talking last night about this you know
when you're studying with people I'll
tell you something when I study with
people I'm not giving you I'm not
telling you this is the way it has to be
done but I've changed my method of
studying with people if I'm studying
with a person and that person up to
study five six seven I mean I don't have
a set study has not received Christ as
their savior I'm done
because here's what happens our message
is a challenging message
so I'm going to go through Jack and I'm
going to study with you and we're going
to get into the state of the dead and
then we're going to get into health and
we're going to get into the mark of the
beast and the Sabbath and all these
things and here's where you are you've
never committed to Christ and you say I
guess if I want to come to Jesus I've
got to change the way I eat I've got to
start keeping the Sabbath and because
that's you've got an unconverted mind
the unconverted mind is all good I'm
just going to see a big wall
it's just going to Heap up more
objections for them to accept the Lord
when you study with somebody have you
ever studied with somebody that hasn't
given their heart to the Lord the study
is like pulling teeth
but when a person has yielded to Jesus
guess what happens
man the study is totally different they
just wanted you know you've got to oh
hold on we'll get to that subject next
time all right what about this what
about this they just want to learn
everything
they want to do everything they want to
give all to the Lord
it's like hold on a minute
Desiree
Desiree is one that we when when she was
before she was baptized it was all man
she wanted to know everything and some
of you you know when you came in it's
like oh I want to learn more I want to
learn more oh wait a minute
you can overdo it but I've I've stopped
study when a person is not I wait to
that person makes that decision for
Christ but the point I'm making in light
of the statement is sometimes we say
well we worry about how to meet all the
objections and we need to know how to
meet objections I'm not saying we don't
but sometimes
some of the objections we have we're
focused on meeting you'll never meet
them because the person is looking for
an excuse they're looking for a way out
there's enough evidence and this is what
sister White's saying here there's
enough evidence in the Bible
for you and I to know we can rest our
faith on it
you know somebody wants to pick it apart
but I mean I love Daniel too Scott went
over Danny two again the other night
um okay the Bible's a fake please
explain that for me
please explain how Daniel 2 has so
accurately outlined history from 600 BC
things that never took place with such
detail let alone the other prophecies
um because some would some guy have a
you know he stayed up late and ate pizza
and he got some you know impression in
his mind and he wrote all this stuff
down no way
it was divinely inspired see we have
enough evidence to rest our faith on
and so she goes on here
they would as easily stumble over plain
facts that the common mind will accept
and discern the Divine and to which
God's utterance is plain and beautiful
full of marrow and fatness all the
mistakes will not cause trouble to One
Soul or cause any feet to stumble that
would not manufacture difficulties from
the plainest revealed truth God
committed the preparation of his
divinely inspired word to finite man hit
this word arranged in books the Old and
New Testament is the guidebook to the
inhabitants of a Fallen World basic
instructions before leaving Earth is
what she's saying there bequeathed to
them that by studying and obeying the
directions not one Soul would lose its
way to heaven
it's in there
it's all in there are people that will
basically Jesus she says if they're
going to manufacture if they're going to
have a difficulty with one thing they'll
manufacture it for anything
you ever study with somebody and meet
their objections they have a an
objection that they well I just okay
let's go to the bot you know you show
them you meet their objection and then
what happens there's another one
and you get there oh then there's
another one anybody ever studied with
the Jehovah's Witness
they never stick to the subject
you get them on this you know they okay
let's look at that uh well what about a
Schwinn they go over here somewhere
and one of the rules in a study is keep
on the subject
and uh anyway any questions on that
no
are you following me are you tired
all right all right very good
just want to make sure
let's look at this issue of lesser light
greater light we talked about this
yesterday just a little bit when we're
going to talk about today just a little
bit
uh Ellen White says in third selected
messages page 30 little heed is given to
the Bible and the Lord has given a
lesser light to lead men and women to
the greater light
incidentally I need to back up a little
when I say that I'm done with a study
after you know when a person hasn't
given their eye doesn't mean I just say
okay we're done here what I try to do is
I try to tailor that study to conversion
topics
you know I try to get and you know
you've got to pray Lord give me wisdom
to know how to find the spot and hit it
just like Jesus did with a rich young
ruler you know good teacher that thing
is oh we don't have time to go into it
it's a powerful
um
anyway Jesus put his truck Jesus put his
finger on the trouble spot for that
young man his whole line of questioning
which Commandments should we keep you
know and people say well Jesus didn't
quote all the Commandments there of
course he didn't he quoted the only ones
he didn't quote
well the ones that were hitting the
trouble spot for that young man
Jesus didn't quote the Commandment that
had to do with covetousness and he
didn't quote the first four Commandments
when you read that account why because
that young man had a problem with
following the Lord with all his heart
mind soul and strength because of his
covetousness and so Jesus quotes those
commands he says I've done these all
already
what else do I lack and then Jesus hit
all the Commandments to be skipped
by saying go sell all you have there's
covenants and come follow me there's the
first four
he knew where the trouble he he baited
the man he brought him right in and then
put him right on the issue it wasn't
even he wasn't giving him a Bible study
in the Sabbath he was giving him a bible
study on conversion
and uh
the man turned away
but when I when I get to a point and I
feel like the person has not made that
commitment I try to tailor things to
that and I just pray for the Lord give
me wisdom to know what to say
because I don't know any better than you
do you say oh you're a pastor you've
done this
we need the Lord all the time when we're
when we're laboring for souls and so you
just pray Lord give me wisdom and help
me to know what to say
have you ever been witnessing to
somebody and leave left the situation
and said man where'd that all come from
I don't know how I said all these ideas
boom boom boom start coming into your
mind praise the Lord that's the Holy
Spirit see he'll give you what to say
so I just didn't want I just wanted to
you know let you know I don't just you
know okay Mark forget it you're not
converted man we're not having a study
you know I try to tailor it around and
if if he shows resistance then I may say
you know Mark
um
maybe maybe I'll check back with you in
a month from now if you if you still
want to study because you know there's a
resistance tend to generally there and
I'll say maybe I'll check back with you
and when you know whatever depending on
the situation but I don't I don't just
say hey we're done buddy you're
unconverted so just so that you
understand that part
a lesser light Ellen White called
herself a lesser light we talked about
the the light of the sun and the light
of the Moon I think we pretty well
covered this I like the example Roger
Koon gave of the the comparing National
maps and state maps you look at a big
atlas map of the whole United States
and you got a big overview
you look at us is that what you're going
to find when you're going in through the
driving through the state
no you take that overview map and you
say oh page whatever that's where the
state is I'm going to and you turn over
to California you'll turn over to
Michigan you turn over to whatever right
because the state map gives you what
greater detail and then when you're
driving around in Detroit have mercy
then what do you do you get a Detroit
map why
greater detail greater detail and in
that way God gave the spirit of Prophecy
to give us greater detail it's the same
light it's the same map it's just more
detail in certain areas you follow that
so that's one example that had been
given on that
um I like what Herbert Douglas says in
his book it's under letter B 4B on the
bottom of page seven Ellen White does
not introduce doctrines that are not in
the Bible we've already talked about
this as well but she does add details
and insights so that those truths are
seen in Greater Clarity with deeper
understanding
and then I summarized something that he
said there if not what would be their
purpose I mean if Ellen White didn't
give us more insight and details
what do we need Ellen White for
you know so yes she gave more details
she gave more insights she didn't make a
new Bible she didn't give us new
doctrines the doctrines are in the Bible
but she has enlightened that which is in
the scripture and pointed us back to the
scripture and say you missed a piece
right here you ever have that happen you
read through the Bible and somebody said
go back up and look at and you're like
oh yeah I never caught that that's what
the spirit of Prophecy does you follow
that does that make sense well we've
already talked about that I want to get
to this last section on this this study
this will kind of launch into the next
part
and that is making of non-effect of the
testimonies
Ellen White says in
uh first selected message is page 48 she
wrote this in 1890 the very last
deception of Satan we believe we're in
the last days don't we so we ought to be
expecting this right now
the very last deception of Satan will be
to make of what
none effect the testimony of the spirit
of God
and then she quotes where there is no
vision the people perish
Satan will work ingeniously in different
ways and through different agencies to
unsettle the confidence of God's Remnant
people in the true testimony
and you could read more of the context
somewhere else the next statement kind
of clarifies what she's talking about
when she talks about the testimony of
the spirit of God obviously we know
that's you know talking about the gift
of Prophecy she says in the next
statement from testimonies four page 211
it is Satan's plan to weaken the faith
of God's people in the testimonies
and when Ellen White speaks of the
testimonies she talks about she's
talking about the testimonies that's
come that have come from her pen
okay next follows not she's not talking
about the eight the nine volume set
testimonies for the church
there was no nine volume set in her day
they hadn't been compiled into that
format she wasn't limiting to that it
was it was the the testimonies that she
speaks of them are the testimonies from
her pen that have come out for God's
people be it in spiritual gifts volume
one two three and four be it in spirit
of Prophecy one two three and four
whatever book was out there uh the
testimonies that she had written
Etc review and Herald articles etc those
were the testimonies from God to his
people the testimony of Jesus she says
it is Satan's plan to weaken the faith
of God's people in the testimonies next
follows skepticism in regard to the
vital points of our faith
uh this is another prediction we could
have looked at this has come true hasn't
it
next follow skepticism in regard to the
vital points of our faith the pillars of
our position then doubt as to the holy
scriptures that's happened well you know
now I don't know if the Genesis account
is accurate this creation really six
days or you know is that just like we
talked about the existential view of
inspiration yesterday
then the downward March she says to
Perdition when the testimonies which
were once believed are doubted and given
up Satan knows the deceived ones will
not stop at this and he redoubles his
efforts till he launches them into open
Rebellion which becomes incurable
it becomes incurable and ends in
destruction
I'm telling you brothers and sisters
what's the what's the uh unpardonable
sin
grieving away the Holy Spirit
and the Holy Spirit speaks to us no
matter what channel he speaks and you
and I reject it
on a consistent basis
that becomes incurable
and we'll talk about that in our next
study my brethren she says in the last
one look at this before I go there this
idea of none effect what does that mean
none effect tell me what that means
huh
she says the devil's going to make the
testimonies of none effect somebody
flesh that out for me
okay do they claim to believe them
they can
they're very well can
you don't have to deny do you let me ask
it this way do you have to deny do you
have to say I don't believe in Ellen
White at all to make the testimonies of
none effect okay
that's a very good word so I believe
that Ellen White was a prophet but what
she wrote was in the 1900s it doesn't
really apply as well today
what have I just done
I've made it of none effect what's
what's the purpose of the testimonies
to help the church and how what's the
purpose for me individually
you know we had a
I had a friend of mine who had he used
to word it this way we played it he said
he played a game called they would call
um he and his
having his friends I met him a little
bit later on and he said yeah when I was
in Academy he says we used to play a
game called testimonies roulette
you've heard a Russian Roulette
right he says we pay testimonies
roulette we pass around the testimony
and one of the guys would get the bullet
right oh that one hit me right you know
and so he worded it that way well that's
the reality
when you read the testimonies you're not
to put you're not your purpose for
reading the testimonies that element's
given is not so you can say
oh yeah mark this is you right here
buddy
and Ron this is you right here that's
not the purpose the purpose is and I
remember I mean when I first started
when I was introduced when and really
start making a plan to read through the
testimonies
um I would get on my knees and I'd say
Okay Lord this morning I want you to
show me in this testimony
this other thing it related it was their
letters the testimonies the nine volumes
those testimonies were letters written
to individuals that doesn't all apply to
me you know I'm not a mom with three
chill crazy children running around the
house and yet there are things in that
testimony that apply to me I said Lord
let me see myself in this testimony okay
the purpose for the gift of prophecy on
an individual basis is to point out
where we have drifted from Christ so we
can get back
and to and to make it irrelevant to my
life I've ruined it I've made it of none
effect I've just destroyed the whole
purpose for the gift of Prophecy in my
life you follow that
and then you can do that also in a
collective basis in a corporate level as
a whole church you know Church board
meeting and the church board says yeah I
know what Alan white says but I think
that this would do better and we don't
have enough money to do that or whatever
other reason
what's the purpose you know for an
individual for the church
any other thoughts on making it of none
effect
yes sir
I'm trying to believe something but are
practicing it people look on
it that's an excellent point
you know Ellen White says something uh
this is a loose paraphrase but she says
something to this effect
truth
is only truth to those who practice it
truth is only truth to those who
practice it
true you see there's too much too many
people today who view truth as a theory
truth is not a theory
truth is a living principle if you are
not putting truth to practice in your
life you're going to band it one of
these days or you know somebody has put
it this way we have Adventists
oftentimes say we have the truth
question we need to ask ourselves is
does the truth have us
truth is only truth to those who
practice it so yes we oh I believe all
Ellen White says
and yet we don't put it to practice in
our own lives we haven't experienced the
truth we'll never know the power of the
truth that way have you ever met
somebody who knows the truth but doesn't
practice it have you been there before I
lived there before and then I was
converted one day praise the Lord
and then I began to understand as I put
it into practice I began to understand
what truth was
truth is only truth to those who
practice it look at the little statement
of the last statement that she wrote to
dear brother Uriah Smith December 31
1890. this is found in manuscript
releases volume four
my brethren have trifold and traveled
and criticized and commented and
demerited and picked and chosen a little
and refused much until the testimonies
mean nothing to them
the worst problem we have is individuals
and as a church as well is picking and
choosing and
making of none effect the testimonies
this is exactly what the Lord said would
happen they put whatever interpretation
upon them that they choose in their own
finite judgment and are satisfied
making of none effect we're told is the
lat one of the last things that the
devil's going to do with this thing with
this gift of Prophecy and indeed we've
seen him do it
and uh all I can say in regard to that
is in your own personal life
I'm not just talking about the
testimonies now but I sure hope you're
not coming here to arise to get ahead
knowledge of something
I mean I you know who had a greater head
knowledge in Christ's day the Pharisees
or the disciples those fishermen
Pharisees and the Sadducees had a much
greater head knowledge Jesus couldn't
use them
those disciples
Jesus was able to use them and their
knowledge their understanding of Truth
was powerful and became way more
powerful why because they put it into
practice in their lives
and uh it's so important for us to have
a living experience with Jesus and with
his word and with his truth
um all the knowledge that we get it'll
be beneficial
if we follow Christ but if we don't
it's just going to condemn Us in the end
everything that we knew to do James says
he who knows the good to do and does not
do it to him in his sin right